hallo Leute hier ist wieder eure
malwanne und mit meinem full face
Make-up werden wir heute den Klinik
Adventskalender testen warum Klinik weil
ich von denen ein Augen
Make-up-Entferner Produkt habe was mir
wirklich sehr gut gefällt und ich immer
schon mal die anderen Produkte testen
wollte und ich dachte dass dieser Klinik
Adventskalender einfach perfekt dafür
ist um
einfach muss da so drin und ich hatte
dieses Jahr
eigentlich Beauty Wellness Make-up
Adventskalender deswegen testen wir den
heute und bevor ihr euch fragt
dieses Video ist gesponsert
und jetzt alle dieses Video ist
gesponsert und zwar von La Land
eigentlich eine App mit der du deine
digitalen Bilder zum Beispiel aus deinem
Handy in Fotogeschenke verwandeln kannst
ich habe jetzt mal ein bisschen was
bestellt und zwar den Klassiker die
Fotobox die gibt es in zwei
verschiedenen Größen und das hier habe
ich für meine Schwiegereltern bestellt
ich habe für mich auch noch eine kleine
Box bestellt die habe ich einfach meine
schönsten Momente die ich ausgedruckt
haben möchte zusammen gesammelt und
daraus kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel was
basteln aber es gibt auch ganz besondere
Sachen wie zum Beispiel Magnete und ich
bin so ein Fan geworden von diesem
Magneten auf unserem Kühlschrank hängt
jetzt acht Mal Timo und ich liebe es
einfach für meine Schwester habe ich
einen Jahreskalender geholt und im April
hat sie Geburtstag deswegen gibt es
dieses Bild dazu einen bestimmten
älter und das ist auch einer meiner
absolut Favoriten und ich bin so happy
dass ich das endlich gemacht habe und
zwar sind das meine Instagram Bilder von
2012 bis 2022 nämlich mit Instagram
verbinden und dann kannst du deine
ganzen Bilder da sehen auswählen und in
dieses Buch einfügen das ist mein erstes
Instagram Foto was ich hochgeladen habe
ja und das Prinzip ist einfach mega easy
ne ihr sucht euch das gut aus was Ihr
haben wollt zum Beispiel hier die
Fotobox dann könnt ihr entscheiden dann
habt ihr classic Mini Box lala-box die
bigibox die oben habt ihr dann Instagram
Facebook Dropbox und Google Fotos ich
habe schon Ordner für meine
Schwiegereltern in meinem Handy erstellt
und kann dann einfach auf diesen Ordner
zugreifen und die ganzen Bilder
aussuchen dann könnt ihr euch
entscheiden ob ihr einen vintage Bild
oder ein 10 * 10 haben wollt und dann ob
es glänzend oder matt sein soll und hier
könnt ihr dann ein Text hinzufügen oder
auch eine Farbe WoW und natürlich gibt's
für euch kleine Mäuschen auch ein
Rabattcode mit mal war eine 30 bekommt
ihr 30% bis zum
31.12.2022 ein Tipp kümmert euch um eure
Geschenke bevor es zu spät ist und jetzt
geht's weiter mit dem Video
das Design wie bei Klinik finde ich ist
das Design sehr gut gelungen die haben
ein tolles Designteam am Start ich weiß
ganz genau was sie damit erreichen
wollen man soll denken oh das ist ganz
wissenschaftlich diese Pflege ne das ist
hier von Experten entwickelt aber
trotzdem noch cute und weihnachtlich
ganz nice wir öffnen die kleine Maus mal
ne
jetzt nicht besonders weihnachtlich aber
also reicht mir aus einzige was ich
schade finde dass man den halt dann
immer wieder so zu klappt also man holt
sich dann eins raus und dann macht man
wieder zu ich sag mal so Rituals ist
Design technisch auf einem ganz anderen
Niveau als das hier
oh mein Gott wurde ich wieder über den
Tisch gezogen und wieder über den Tisch
gezogen bei Zalando kostet der 84 95 bei
Flaconi kostet der
69,95 da hatte ich 15 € gespart Douglas
macht so 95 €. ich bin gerade wieder so
verwirrt warum sind plötzlich die Preise
von den Kalender so unterschiedlich auf
jeder Webseite
61 €, ich habe das Gefühl da sind die
ganzen scam Webseite was kann ich auch
nicht sein der Preis liegt von 62 € bis
95 je nachdem wo ihr ihn schießt sehr
gut wir finden ja den Warenwert draußen
Vanessa warum hast du so ein
wunderschönes voll face Make-up also du
siehst ja komplett zugeklatscht aus
damit ich es Weg reinigen kann und wie
auch irgendwie was testen können
ich habe heute auf meinen Kalender
geguckt und der Dezember ist einfach
schon so richtig nah dran ich meine ich
packe seit 2 Monaten adventskinder aus
ich weiß dass es langsam Ende des Jahres
ist aber heute habe ich so eine
realitätsstelle gehabt
schon benutzen ist das so schritt eins
milde flüssige Gesichtsseife für
trockene bis Mischhaut das ist eine
Probe Größe nee 200 ml kosten 24 €, das
sind 30 ml 3,60 €. ja benutzen wir
gleich ich ich mache jetzt mal ein paar
Tücher
okay okay okay es ist eine drei Skin
Cash drei Schritte skincare Schritt 1
Schritt 2 zu wissen dass die ganz
komplett glutenfrei sind und natürlich
dermatologisch getestet und hergestellt
klar wir haben Schritt 1 und jetzt auch
Schritt 2 und das ist jetzt so ein
exfoliator also ein Peeling müsste ja in
Türchen Nummer drei Schritt Nummer drei
drin sein ne das wäre ja logisch
nein wir machen Schritt eins und Schritt
zwei drei aber Schritt 3 machen wir
nicht rein was ist das stimmt Klinik hat
ja auch Make-up ich glaube es nicht in
Eyeliner oh nein nein nein man kann ihn
nicht mehr rein reden
wenn hier schon Make-up drin ist dann
testen wir das auch gleich aus boah der
sind Hills gucken wir mal nach den
Preisen Nummer 2 war Clarifying Lotion
360 jetzt bin ich gespannt was der
quickliner kostet den gibt's gar nicht
so wie sie in den verkaufen nicht für
den Einzelverkauf hier steht drauf nicht
einzeln Verkäufer kaufbar das heißt es
ist eine günstigere Version von dem
quickliner für Smokey Eyes der hat nicht
dieses komische Ding da dran mach mal 15
€ auch wenn das in 10 viel ist dafür
Türchen Nummer vier was ist so ein
Türchen Nummer 4 ja es sind halt Probe
Größen ne ich meine bei den Preisen all
about us Mann ich dachte ich kann
einfach alles benutzen um mich zu
pflegen und so aber wenn er jetzt immer
Make-up noch dazwischen sein wird
kommt wir gehen uns jetzt ich gehe mich
jetzt waschen wir gucken mal ganz kurz
alle beide baut eins kostet oh mein Gott
13 € finde bisschen okay lass uns
waschen gehen
jetzt einfach mal das Gesicht
bloß nicht zu viel verwenden drin ist
riecht das ein bisschen
medizinisch
ja
oh das stinkt aber nach Alkohol ich
glaube das hätte ich mit dem Pad
auftragen müssen die meine
wiederverwendbaren
Pets ich mache das noch mal so erinnert
mich ein bisschen an Nagellackentferner
gerade riecht noch so als ob es mit
Alkohol meine Haut explodiert meine Haut
fühlt sich so ein bisschen an wie ein
Teenager Zeit als ich so dieses
aggressive Pickel Zeugs benutzt haben
also ein bisschen gereizt ne Nummer fünf
vielleicht bekommen wir etwas um den
Lippenstift und die Wimpern zu schlafen
take the day of make-up Remover
einmal schütteln das ist das Produkt was
ich auch schon kenne
im Kalender ist eigentlich bestes
Marketing packen da Produkte rein
man kann sich einmal durch testen und
dann mag man ein Produkt und kaufe das
wieder und wieder und wieder da ist der
Lippenstift benutze die andere Seite für
die Augen ganz vorsichtig ich weiß noch
nicht was ich zu diesem
wiederverwendbaren Wattepads halte die
sind mir so ein bisschen zu rau dieser
schwarze hält aber warum ist 125 ml
kosten 24 € 56
€, das Make-up zu was du dir selber
drauf gemacht hast
Nummer sechs wir sehen schon richtig
toll aus nach unseren kliniksachen und
wir haben Nikolaus und gucken was in
unserem Schule drin ist jetzt können wir
uns wieder von vorne schminken
mit unserem Blush Blush das Ding hier
kostet 24 Euro wieder drin ich benutz
den jetzt nicht und pack den euch in die
verlosungsbox rein Nikolaus Tür ne
Nummer 7 ist sehr sehr lang in der
Nummer 7 befindet sich ein Klinik sind
tätig Pinsel da steht ganz groß drauf
China wenn die Qualität ist in Ordnung
die Pinsel aber ich weiß nicht warum man
so ein festen haben Pinsel braucht
ein bisschen anderen Kopf ich gebe den
30 €. 30
Minuten
ist wirklich eine
kann man glaube ich an dieser Stelle
jetzt sagen und ich kann auch jetzt
nicht bei jedem Türchen sagen oh mein
Gott ist das teuer ich glaube wir müssen
uns jetzt einfach damit arrangieren okay
wir haben das jetzt verarbeitet die
Sachen sind hier drin sind teuer Nummer
acht wir haben jetzt einfach auch mal
eine ganz andere Editor okay mein Vater
gehört Batzen und natürlich schenkt er
mir einen Klinik Adventskalender Klinik
die Komfort Handcreme die werde ich
wieder mal ich benutzen denn ich habe so
viel Handcreme dass ich das nicht tun
würde 11,80 € klar
Nummer 9 Nummer 9 ihr wisst das wird
jetzt das beste Türchen sein ich freue
mich schon darauf ich glaube Lippenstift
oh mein Gott ich war so nah dran ein
Lipgloss und auf Lipgloss habe ich
extrem Lust
boah der ist wunderschön der diese
perfekte Kombination von lässt deine
Lippen ganz schön feucht nass glänzend
aussehen aber ohne so Glitzerpartikel
und das ist halt too much aussieht müsst
ich wusste ich werde fern ich werde Fan
ich mag schon das Augen
make-up-entfernungszeug und jetzt bin
ich Fan und jetzt werde ich da so viel
Geld ausgeben und die haben ganz genau
das erreicht was sie mit diesem Kalender
erreichen wollten ja das ist doch genau
hier mein typchen wie viele sind 4,3
drin ich sag mir jetzt einfach die
Hälfte der schon sehr klein 13 € mein
Gesicht braucht jetzt echt Creme
deswegen ist in der 11 in der zehn das
war gerade natürlich in Nummer 9 ich
sage euch Leute natürlich Nummer 9 sind
die besten gibt es jetzt Creme
take the day of clansing-ball und das
ist von der gleichen Reihe wie das
make-up-entfernungszeug cremiger
Make-up-Entferner der ist für
wimpernlippen und Augenlidern und der
ist für die Wangen ganz ehrlich das
probieren wir aus ich könnte mich dran
gewöhnen immer gleich die Sachen auch
auszuprobieren oh der hat so eine feste
Kokosöl Konsistenz sagen warum benutzen
genauso gut weg ich weiß
mag so mein Make-up zu entfernen weil
das Gefühl das geht dann richtig in die
Poren rein außerdem
natürlich das jetzt gerne mit dem
richtigen Make-up gemacht aber bestimmt
noch die Reste aus den Poren geholt mein
Gesicht fühlt sich jetzt wieder weicher
an zum plus 4 € 30 Türchen Nummer 11 mit
Creme eine Creme eine Creme und wieder
was zum Waschen feuchtigkeitsspendendes
Konzentrat wir sind so Punkte drin ich
weiß nicht ob das irgendwas wirklich
bringen soll oder ob das so ein
optischer Effekt ist so sieht wieder
ganz wissenschaftlich aus also das soll
hier hydrieren ohne Ende toll sieht es
aus diese Kügelchen sind ganz fest was
willst du denn auf der Haut auf oder was
riecht wieder sehr neutral also nicht
performiert natürlich und so ja so wie
die Frauen wir sind Korea beigebracht
haben
richtig reinprügeln das Zeug wir haben
was soll ich sagen tolle Textur fühlt
sich super an
Scheiße mist
ich kann mir so ein Zeug doch nicht
kaufen dann gebe ich doch 100 € im Monat
alleine für aus das reichhaltige
Feuchtigkeitspflege auf Wasser versorgt
die dritte Haut sofort spendet der Haut
24 und 72 72 Stunden lang volligkeit
hier
12,50 € für diese kleine Probe ich bin
gespannt auf meine Haut irgendwann mal
so richtig reagiert glaube ich gar nicht
mochte ist dieser exfoliator
ich habe für einen Moment gedacht ne
aber nee weißt Scheiße Lotion very dry
to drive Kombination Skin 3 von 3 step
komisch dass sie beim Anfang diese
ersten beiden steps gegeben haben und
dann aber nicht Nummer drei irgendwie
triggert mich das so ein bisschen Creme
hier ich glaube die Creme muss richtig
reichhaltig sein weil ja die fühlt sich
reichlich für trockene das trockene Haut
im Winter könnte sie aber gut sein weil
ich da zu trockener Haut seid so komisch
weil es halt einfach nicht riecht ne
also bzw es riecht so ich will nicht
sagen muffig aber es ist
wichtig aber nicht nur fähig das schon
natürlich also das so jetzt können
Schlamm sein und altes Stück Holz
irgendwie so dramatic Lied different
moistracing Lotion klar
die Größe
natürlich schreibe ich auch 14 es macht
Spaß ja ja ja ja ja jetzt geht's rund
rund
Probe was ist das natürlich in der 14
haben wir wirklich den kleinsten
Lippenstift der Welt obwohl tschüss
relativ viel drin aber ja da Nummer eins
Lipgloss mich überzeugt hat darfst jetzt
auch die Lippenstift ich bin bei so
Probe begrüßen was Make-up angeht gar
nicht selbst weil man ja eh so selten
ein Produkt mal wirklich bis zum Ende
benutzt ich liebe ihn und nein ja ich
finde den Mega
der ist irgendwie auffällig aber so
unauffällig auffällig sieht einfach aus
wie tolle gepflegte Lippen also 3,9 ich
mache wieder die Hälfte 13 Euro 15 na
kann ich mir noch was ins Gesicht
schmieren wasserlösliches Creme Peeling
oh ich habe lange kein Peeling stimmt
nee dachte da ist irgendwie so
Salzkristalle oder so drin aber nein das
ist einfach nur eine Creme nee irgendwas
ist da doch drin was ganz fein
9,75 €. oh nein ich habe Türchen 13
übersprungen Entschuldigung sowas läuft
hier
ein bisschen
leiser wasserlöslicher Reinigungsschaum
auch wieder ein Produkt was das Gesicht
reinigt wir haben ja verschiedene Serien
also die haben immer wieder dieselben
Produkte aber von der anderen Serie
andere Bedürfnisse 3,60 €, 3,3,60 €. ja
3,60 €. das ist ja ein Schnapper hier
okay jetzt machen wir wieder ein Sprung
zurück zu Nummer 16 ja voll und noch
mehr Lippen Produkte Charlie Stick
moistracing Lipan ich weiß ja nicht
inwiefern die Produkte das dann wirklich
schaffen was sie versprechen aber ich
mag diese Kombination aus es sieht gut
aus und macht halt irgendwie auch
nochmals driving oder was auch immer und
das sind jetzt endlich mal aus wie ein
normales Produkt
okay ich sehe nichts
er hat das Gefühl das nimmt nur
Lippenfarbe und also es fühlt sich
wieder gut an ich sehe jetzt aber nicht
wirklich ein Unterschied zu dem
Lippenstift außer dass es vielleicht ein
bisschen reichhaltiger sich anfühlt aber
ich finde es nicht schlecht aber auch
nicht gut auch so viele gute Bewertung
was schreiben denn die Leute dazu auch
ohne Konturenstift sauber und super in
der Anwendung das klingt doch nicht wie
ein echtes Kommentar nur Zuschauer wie
sie glauben den Scheiß dann auch noch so
dumm 1 2 Gramm haha also die Hälfte 10 €
und ich habe glaube ich bei manchen ein
bisschen zu gut gerechnet 17 das Türchen
Nummer 17 gefällt mir ganz besonders gut
Smart clinical repair hier sind wir
schon wieder auf der wissenschaftlichen
Seite ne Winkel korrection i cream soll
das jetzt hier in die Augenfalten area
reincremen ne auch immer ganz vorsichtig
wenn man die Augen eincremth wow hätte
den Unterschied das ist wie Tag und
Nacht nein also ich bin großer Fan von
Augencreme mein Video gesehen von einer
die sich Augencreme immer vorher auf
ihre Handrücken gemacht hat bevor sie
das aufs Auge aufgetragen hat und dann
hat sie hier einfach so eine Stelle
gehabt wo Ihre Haut so richtig fresh
aussahen Gegensatz zu anderen Hand habe
ich gedacht oh warum brennt es na ja was
soll diese Augencreme Kosten ich rate 90
€ dieses Töpfchen wir haben gesagt wir
sind over it 20 €
19,33 €. das ist immer das gleiche bin
immer kein Fan von gleich auseinander
aber es ist jetzt Augenwinkel nein und
nicht für die Augen oh was Falten
korrigierende Serum also nicht Augen
verwenden Sie ein wirksames
Sonnenschutzmittel schränken Sie den
Aufenthalt in der Sonne für die Dauer
der Anwendung dieses Produktes auch noch
eine Woche danach das wird hier nicht
gezeigt also wenn du das sagst das ist
toll vertraue ich ihn
hierbei Winkels ich habe noch keine
wirklichen Falten also ja habe ich aber
jetzt nicht wirklich Verhalten ich
strahle und bin Klett
wartet mal wie viel es kostet denn denn
denn denn denn 20 €. es wird alt die
Sprüche werden alt ja das ist teuer 19
Maske und die ist wirklich
Glitzer Kleinigkeit spendende
Gesichtsmaske für die Nacht war eure 66
okay jetzt ist hier schon wieder alle
baut Dingen zwei eins clansing und
experience ich hätte gern so ein Schutz
hier drin gehabt ehrlich gesagt bei dem
Wetter muss man auch sonst Schutz
benutzen und ich habe irgendwie noch
kein gutes falls ihr einen guten
Sonnenschutz habt schreibt ihr mir gerne
mal in die Kommentare weil ich bin da
irgendwie noch überfragt 5 € 80 für
unser jelly ausprobieren werden weil
meine Haut schreit aber das Wimpern das
Augencreme ich habe einen Brand aber es
ist nicht so dass ich es abwaschen muss
aber es ist das brennt schon 21 unser
Kalender ist jetzt volljährig in Amerika
ich glaube das hatte ich mal das ist
jetzt schon Augencreme Nummer drei ne
Augen moistress search was ist das hier
steht jetzt einfach nichts auf Deutsch
drauf jetzt spontan entschieden oder wie
ja ähm das benutze ich jetzt nicht das
ist halt die nächste Augenpflege ne die
Augen Version sehe ich jetzt hier nicht
2,60 €. 22
100 Stunden seid ihr denn verrückt use
under or over Make-up or as A5 Minute
mask geh einfach was Du willst damit mir
das traurig mir das nicht drauf Hacks
übers Make-up und das Make-up das ist
einfach nur pure Feuchtigkeit
oh mein Gott das fühlt sich wirklich
super feucht an mein Gesicht fühlt sich
richtig nass an sieht auch plötzlich
finde ich super Nass aus Samen und das
Make-up packen 21 €, das macht das
Gesicht aber schön Release ne für 21 €
völlig wirklich also das nasses Gesicht
toll 21
vorletzte Türchen unser Gesicht glänzt
noch ungefähr 72 Stunden weiter und wir
machen das nächste Produkt auf
dieses klinikel das ist even better
clinical das ist alles Radio dogs
Podcast was ist das denn ich habe sogar
im Dunkeln
also nicht dass man seine dunklen
Flecken korrigieren kann
nee also ich wüsste jetzt nicht was
dunkle Flecken sind nicht mal [ __ ]
gerade hier einfach irgendwas an dunkle
Flecken ich kenne nur dunkle Flecken bei
wirklich alte Haut also wenn du so 60
plus bist dann kriegt man halt so
Altersflecken aber das ist macht ja
nicht weg 22,30 €, das sichtbar das
Aussehen von dunklen Flecken altes
Flecken und Akne Narben verbessert also
auch die Altersflecken aber das müsste
das doch dann die Haut bleachen es ist
soweit der 24 es ist Weihnachten ja wir
haben viele Produkte aufgemacht und
freuen uns jetzt auf das ganz besondere
Produkt der Mascara von Klinik ich kenne
den Mascara und ich glaube mich zu
erinnern dass der sehr gut war oh ja und
hier kann man auch 100 mal drüber gehen
es wird nicht klumpig so sieht der
ausländisch
toll ja geiles geiles Produkt bei der
Wimperntusche haben sie Vollzeit gegönnt
26,50 €. oh mein Gott was sind das hier
für Preise jetzt mal wirklich gut ich
rechne dann jetzt einmal zusammen der
schönste Teil jetzt ist die Frage lohnt
sich der Klinik Adventskalender ja
100%
288 59 2 also ich habe ungefähr 88 € ja
bezahlt 200 € man bekommt Waren im Wert
von 200 € es noch mal oben drauf ja was
haben wir zu den Produkten ich finde den
super ich weiß ich war vorgenommen weil
ich einfach Klinik schon von dem
augenentfernungszeug gut fand deswegen
wollte ich auch mal wirklich wissen wie
sich die anderen Produkte so anfühlen
und ich bin so überrascht aber Klinik
Make-up ist wirklich sehr sehr gut und
ich hatte das überhaupt gar nicht mehr
so auf dem Schirm ja meine Haut fühlt
sich gut an das einzige jetzt ist wieder
besser geworden das einzige war dieses
Serum was mir ein bisschen an den Augen
gebrannt hat ich ich finde den gut aber
wenn man wenn man den Umfang sieht dann
ist es wirklich sehr wenig für 288 €.
und das was mit dem Video ich hoffe euch
hat also
ne geht ihr gleich weiter